after a couple of big screen appearances
Jason Momoa as Aquaman is finally
stepping out on his own with his first
solo adventure whether you're a longtime
comics reader or completely unfamiliar
with this classic characters legacy
here's everything you need to know
before seeing Aquaman Aquaman wasn't
always a sea-based superhero he was born
Arthur curry 1/2 atlante and half human
boy whose mother Queen atlanna was
forced to leave him in the care of his
human father Thomas curry however and
being split between these two worlds
Arthur is rejected by both sides of his
heritage and in the end he finds himself
somewhat lost I feel like never really
embraced sea or the land life as an
adult Arthur must find his place in both
worlds Viper's right to become king of
Atlantis and protect the world at large
Aquaman has a wide range of powers
including super-strength extreme
durability the ability to breathe
underwater and the power to control any
undersea life-forms Aquaman has been
around for a while his first appearance
came in more fun comics issue 73 in 1941
as a backup character to other heroes
Aquaman lived on in the back pages of
adventure comics and during the 1960's
finally joined the Justice League got
his own cartoon series and became one of
the Superfriends cementing his legacy
director James Wan has said that his
Aquaman movie it's largely inspired by
writer Geoff Johns who rebooted the
character in 2011 still one didn't leave
the older comics behind he went through
dozens of Aquaman comics from the past
70 years of source material for fans of
the cheesy older comics
don't worry because one couldn't was
just using some elements from these eras
so PO Aquaman's octopus sidekick will
appear in the film fans were likely
surprised to hear about Nicole Kidman's
casting in Aquaman since she hasn't
appeared in a superhero film since 1995
Batman Forever
however Kidman will be officially
joining the DC Universe as Queen atlanna
a superhuman mother of Aquaman it's
still unclear how faithful the film will
be as far as the original comics are
concerned but it looks as if Kidman
story will be a tragic one your mother
left you to save your life can't imagine
how we hurt him what it cost her Alana
has been written as an outcast a queen
and more importantly Aquaman's linked to
his superhuman heritage and his one
connection to Atlantis however she's
also been written as a fairly absent
parent so if this film is including
Aquaman's family history audiences may
see some tension between the tow played
by Amber Heard Mira was first seen in
justice league to provide backstory for
Aquaman but her role and Aquaman will be
much more substantial director James Wan
has remarked that Aquaman is more like
Mira's sidekick once mira appears
on-screen in Aquaman she's reportedly in
nearly every single scene it's not hard
to guess why one chose to focus on
mirrors so much as a character as a
powerful superhero in her own right she
possesses incredible strength and the
ability to completely control water it
seems as if Mira's origin story has been
changed considerably compared to the
original comics though Mira usually
hails from an alternate dimension
Justice League revealed a different
origin but she was raised by Queen
atlanna as a war orphan when my parents
fought in the wars
she took me sibling rivalry abounds in
superhero films and Aquaman will be no
exception in late 2016 it was announced
that Patrick Wilson had signed on as
Aquaman's early and powerful
half-brother arm in the comics or as a
contender for the throne of Atlantis and
the nearly destroys a scene his attempts
to claim the crown in the film however
some environmentally minded audience
members may side more with arm than
Aquaman in their central conflicts on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert
Wilson discuss Tom's motivations my
whole point of the movie is to get back
at the surface world has been polluting
my oceans our oceans a little bit of
environmental theme going in there
Wilson is no stranger to superhero films
as he previously appeared in sack
Snyder's 2009 watchman adaptation as
night owl he's also familiar with
Aquaman's director having appeared in
one's horror hits insidious and the
conjuring alcaman has his work cut out
for him in the film in addition to
facing again storm will have to deal
with Black Manta another villain from
the original comics as a ruthless pirate
who will stop at nothing to destroy
Atlantis
Black Manta harbors a long-held grudge
against the underwater metropolis he's
also a brilliant engineer who designed a
diving suit which gives him
super-strength suits optic blasts and
allows him to survive in the water one
has been extra quiet regarding Black
Manta specifics fans only know that Yaya
Abdul Mateen the second who appeared on
Netflix's to get down will be playing
the villain Aquaman has one very
well-known power the Aquaman here you
can talk to fish this has made our man
the subject of many a joke over the
years but one isn't shying away from
this particular power and fans who
expect our commands fished telepathy to
play a big part in the film
[Music]